pour que je sorte la suite j'aurais dû
dire ça donc les familles soient là et
doumé mais cette fille n'est pas faite
pour lui
tu l'as dis toi même je sais jamais
vraiment beaucoup plus embarrassante que
ce que j'avais imaginé
alors qu'elle est là il faut que tu
l'aimés dit ça y est tu me rappelles tu
en a fallu du temps subi arrête de faire
chier de zone je suis à poil en plein
milieu du mexique
j'ai voulu rejoindre l'hôtel pour
récupérer 6 me suis fait braquer le
climat bagnols et mon petit tu aimais
prague
j'aurais pu être mariée on regarde tout
ça commence à devenir des cas une
personne ne va te des caméras sur quoi
célébrer n'est pas une arme vous
accueille au lycée je vais jouer de
manger pour toute la cocaïne
on se parle pas couvert de la coke un
autre mec
nardo est en galère au mexique il a
voulu rejoindre tracy faut qu'on aille
le sauver vous y allez à tient au
mexique
il nous faut une pièce d'identité pour
passer aux mecs vous chéri qu'est ce qui
se passe aux amis de kenny une fabrique
une fausse carte d'identité m'en donner
de l'argent pour que je prenne une photo
de mes couilles c'est une mission de
sauvetage à une virée entre potes
fassi fihri verre d'eau ou est ce que tu
es dans une prison mexicaine
non merde c'est qui ça donne
fabriquer cette fille faut s'amuser vous
des mairies
pourquoi vous dites ça
est ce qu'on a fait des cauchemars et
non mais dis moi tu m'enlèves tard mais
on n'ouvre derrière normalement
chirurgien oui nous ont coupés en foot
jusqu'à ce qu'on trouvera on l'arraché
et on se casse troquer